for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university calm
thank you and enjoy so next up is row 4
of the periodic table and actually just
real foreign beyond it so in this one
I'm not going to actually go through the
entire electron configuration I'm just
gonna do the condensed electron
configuration for the sake of time and
space but we're still using the Aufbau
sort of principle so we're gonna go one
s and then 2 s and then 2p and then 3 s
and so on and so forth 3p 4s that's
what's going on here and that's kind of
where we are with Row 4 so with
potassium K 19 electrons argon has 18 so
18 electrons were accounted for here one
more electron would be for s1 right
because argon is up to 3 p6 so the next
would be 4s and there's only one
electron so potassium for us one after
argon calcium would just be one more
right so would be everything up until
argon and then for s2 so then then we
have the transition elements scandium
atomic number 21
so it'd be 4 s 2 and then 3 D 1 and
we're going to continue doing that right
just following elf battle right so for
s2 all right then we have 3 D 1 so we're
gonna have 3 deep we're gonna fill 3 D
and then we're gonna have 4 P 5 s and so
on and so forth so we're gonna do this
all the way through zinc for the
transition elements then we're going to
keep going further I got little stars
here and I'll get to that in a second
but the idea is that if you continue
using the Alpha principal guidelines
which basically involves using this
thing here right you'll get the expected
electron configuration you won't always
get the actual electron configuration
and the reason why is because there are
some exceptions or anomalies that are
kind of weird we'll talk about that in
the next video
but basically though for elements beyond
row 4 you just use the Aufbau principle
guidelines and just be mindful of the
anomalies once you know them
so I'll get to that in the next video so
hope that video is helpful thanks for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying